hi everyone
my name is i'm 20 years old
and i'm currently attending wellesley
college in boston area in the us
and i'm focusing on both computer
science and
uh in the past i attended uh well from
summer school in 2018 and also both from
summer camp as a ta in 2018 2019 and
2020
and i always highly recommend these two
programs to anyone i need um
so today's talk is called computational
farming and it's something i
became curious about in high school and
i didn't even know existed
so my talk will be more of like an
introduction to this
new field
so as you may know our population is
growing
which forces us to think about more
innovation
in sustainable and efficient farming and
one of the things that people are doing
right now is trying to incorporate ai
and the fastest growing application of
ai currently is called precision farming
precision farming is kind of like an
equivalent of computational farming
which relies on um
relies on the collection interpretation
analysis of diverse forms of digital
data
and i really like this picture because
it really shows how
today our um like physical
fields of crops are not just physical
but also digital
because they represent huge amounts of
data
as you can see here um now we can
both analyze a physical field and as
well as like
the digital field as we collect
information
so let me go
um yes so precision forming
um as i said relies on the collection
interpretation analysis
of diverse forms of digital data and
it offers new ways for farmers to
analyze their crops
and make better management decisions in
problems
such as allocating labor or wearing
storage using water fertilizers
pesticides
[Music]
and for example precision farming can
also provide
tools that can for example track
harvest yield and allow for the analysis
of field variability
like differences in soil makeup water
fungus
and variable rates technologies provide
predictions and analysis so that farmers
may customize
the amount of input such as fertilizer
or pesticide
on any portion of a field and in my
research
i am focusing more on smaller farms
um like even orchards because as you may
know
bigger farms they have more resources so
they have
more opportunity to try new
technologies especially that are data
based
but smaller farms they don't have the
same advantage
so that's why in my research i wanted to
explore new technologies that can be
applied
on smaller farms and one of them
is called normalized difference
vegetation english it's this
information you can get about your
vegetation and use it to make better
management decisions
so this is like the first example of
what i see is computational farming
involved
language is creating this ndvi
function so basically um healthy
vegetation
usually absorb um and do not reflect
red light so it absorbs red light and
strongly reflects
near infrared light and that's why this
information
can be used to apply a false
color gradient for example to images to
better highlight the contrast between
regions of healthy vegetation
versus areas with like stress or
deceased or
no vegetation so this is just a pretty
simple index but it gives us a lot of
information
about vegetation that we have on our
like orchards or farms
and ndvi in particular as i said it's
like this
dimensionless index that describes the
difference between
the visible and the near-infrared
reflectance of vegetation cover
and can be used to estimate the density
of like green on an area of
land so it goes from zero
to one usually and one indicates
like a very healthy crop and
zero is more like it's dead and there's
like in between
so this is something we can already use
and get some information
so but for that we need to take
quiet above the fields and take pictures
um so the drone itself is just like a
pretty uh cheap commercial drone like
compared to
the ones that they usually use in like
more advanced research
so this one had a single camera
which i modified so i modified the
camera
to capture both near-infrared and red
light
because that's what we need to see if
the vegetation is healthy or not
but i do it in the same image however in
different
color channels so for the red light
i would try to make it go through the
lid red channel
and they're near infrared i use it in
the blue channel
i'll explain later how that works um and
so this is like an affordable
alternative to
making a system that usually uses like
three to
two to three cameras or sensors um
that i've seen and like researched them
before
so i just wanted to make something that
uh people can use
um in like on smaller farms that don't
have
enough resources to create this like
very difficult systems um
so yeah for the camera the first thing
to do
is to remove the infrared filter that's
like part of most cameras because we
need that information so we removed the
filter
and i bought this um another filter that
only allows
red light so as you can see uh 660
nanometers
so red light passes through and near
infrared light also passes through and
the rest
is like blocked um so the incorporation
of this filter it allows
for the the reflected red light to be
captured in camera
sensors red channel and the near
infrared light is going to be captured
in the blue channel
and the yacht the green channel is just
like not used at all
so this is how it looks um
and we use the drone to take pictures of
uh vegetation
for my like testing i just did it on a
piece of grass which is not that
fun but um i'm gonna be explaining how i
did it with the grass
and this is the post-processing in
mathematica um
so this is the original photo this is
grass as you can see
it was like more closer to fall i guess
and some vegetation started to
die you see it's the near infrared they
would absorb it and
like it would just burn it so there's
some parts that are healthy and others
that are not
so we have this the original picture and
then this one is with the filter
that i just used that only allows red
indian red light to go through
um so the uh one issue that i had with
this filter actually is that i had some
optical operations as you can see like
on the angles
um yeah it's like not really correct so
i didn't know why that's happening but
the information in the middle was still
okay so i
i'm just like cropping here um i cropped
the borders using image crop
just identified dimensions and this is
what we
did we have our final image
that is cropped and this is what we're
gonna use
to see which parts of vegetation healthy
which are not
gonna be called crop sample so
yes now we want to extract the two
channels that have information that we
need the blue and the red
red contains international red light and
blue about neo infrared
so we use color separate on the crop
sample
and we include blue and red channels so
we get these two images
of just the blue channel and the red
channel
and now we can use these two images to
apply
our ndi function on so individual
function
as i said equals the nearest light minus
red light over an
infrared plus red light and we apply
this function every single pixel of the
two images
so this is our formula and then when we
apply
and blue chance yes applies to every
pixel but at first we get this
black image so we need to just adjust
the picture
we can see any difference but when we do
image adjust
we can see uh now the difference um
and as i said uh the lighter colors will
like indicate healthier vegetation so
these parts should be like healthy
pretty much and then
the darker it is the more like stressed
or deceased or
even like completely dead parts of
vegetation
um yeah so this is like our final enzyme
map
but also we can improve it a little bit
better because we can't really see well
it's like black and white
not very useful um so we're gonna just
do colorize it
um we use colorize we see it a little
bit better
this time it's like the more blue
it is or like lighter divorced
vegetation and the more red the more
healthy it is
but also we can do conform images
um to deconform they confirm the
original photo
and our end by map to get an even better
representation of what's happening
so and conform images it just like
returns
uses a list of images and returns images
of the same properties like dimensions
just like adjusts to the same dimensions
data types color space
and interleaving and then we multiply
the two
and now we can see much clearly
what is happening like the areas that
are more red they're more healthy um
in the areas that are like bluer lighter
they're just like
not as healthy so this is one
way um to get some information about
our vegetation on the farm just by
taking a picture
using a simple filter that filter cost
maybe
i think 70 dollars so yeah and this is
the final function
now in the web map we can apply to any
like original picture
um that was taken with like a divert
filter
and um yeah so some applications
um instead of just looking at a
particular spot we can try and like look
at the whole
form and see which areas of the form
might be
maybe like stressed or having some
issues if you want to like have a bigger
picture
um this picture is from the internet i
didn't actually
take um that far away so it's not the
best one but i think you get the idea
so you can use it on like bigger scale
um
yeah so this is how like the whole
function works
and something small and useful um
yeah there was another implementation um
so after i told about this project at
the summer camp
one of our students erin patel he used
the ndvi
function and he looked at uh
compared the uh the filterized
fertilizers
um on vegetation that like he was
growing and it showed that
his knowledge life that he was testing
was actually as effective
as the current synthetic fertilizers but
also even
outperforming its organic peers so i
think you use duckweed and he'll compare
it to other fertilizers
and just by using nzbi you could already
get pretty
good information about your vegetation
so and yeah
this is obviously like very exciting
because it opens
the door to like completely thinking how
we fertilize our crops
um just based on this one index and
there's obviously many more indexes like
this you can look at
nitrogen level um just like
all sorts of information but it's like
the basic one
um so another example of computational
farming um
is trying to count the amount of
like what we grow in our trees it could
be oranges apples whatever
uh because farmers actually really
appreciate this information
because they need to like see how many
people they need to hire
to collect um their fruits and see how
much storage they will need
and basically like it's usually pretty
useful to know how much
um you have to collect at the end of
your harvest
um so yeah the question is just how can
we
count all these oranges
so yes food detection counting um uh
at first i tried to see if anyone
had like an algorithm to do this if i do
research in this area
and there was only really one group at
japan
who collected this huge data set of just
like taking picture of
uh trees um like making videos
and um they collect information about
where they
each like fruit is i think here is like
apples here's oranges and then they had
information about
um like the x and y where the fruit is
and then also the radius so it's like
very detailed
um but at first um and they used
actually deep learning but i didn't want
to go
right through deep learning and at first
i tried to
just see if i can do it in mathematica
using the
um the functions that they do have in
here
which i think i it's like a good idea to
do before you jump into deep learning
because not every
problem can be solved with just
deploying i know it's like
very like you just want to go to deep
learning sometimes but
um here i'm trying to see if i can do it
with like regular functions
that we have um yeah so at first
um i'm just like trying to see how this
works i bannerize it
well this didn't look good at all so i'm
just
using um now like
a value um oh yeah at first yeah it's
just like separating the foreground the
background
uh with the threshold so i put it to 0.3
just something that worked for me better
uh but it can be like between
one and zero it creates this binary
image that looks a little bit better
than before so you can see some fruits
already
not that overlapping and then i just use
select components
and choose components that are
uh based on like eccentricity and
circularity
um this is just how round it is and i
input it 0.7
i think oh um
yeah and 0.8 oh god okay um
um
[Music]
yes okay so this worked
not too bad i see now the fruit's a
little bit better
but it removed a lot of the other ones
and
so what we can do next is to use
distance transform um in order
to like separate the overlapping apples
because there are some
um and we do that by extracting like a
set of markers
by finding uh local maximas of the
distance transform
and we use these markers later in
watershed components and
after that we will be able to count the
apples so distance transform
um this is how it works basically
um the value of each pixel of an image
is going to be replaced by
its distance to the nearest background
pixel
so if you look at it like a picture of
like a horse this is how it's going to
be
the distance transform so we do the same
apply
on our original picture and we get this
image
um let's see
yeah so this is what we get and then
after that we
are um finding areas in this like
elevation map basically it's
right now looks like an elevation map um
that rise above
uh the surroundings but like a certain
threshold and for me i use a 0 i use 0.1
uh it could be anything you want but i'm
using 0.1
that looks better so i'm creating a
marker
you can see there's some more dots
and then after that i'm using watershed
components
that uses like a binary image marker
this one
and um to indicate regions where basin
basins may be created um
so we apply watershed components this is
what we get we also colorize it
and now we can see after we colorize it
each component is like a different color
and then we just use
max the function x and we get 16. so
this is like amount of
apples i guess we have here which is not
which might not be true but it's at
least something
that we can get already using the
functions and if you want to play more
with parameters
and see which ones work better uh if we
combine all the functions together
we can use this like manipulate
functions and see
which parameters might work better if we
change it
the distance for example uh we get a
little bit less
fruits maybe the mean size is like
yeah we can just play see which one
works better but i think the one that i
had before was like
pretty ideal yeah so yeah this is how
you can
try and like calculate number of fruits
on trees
just by using um functions in
mathematica
and um the original approach was
definitely deep learning
um because the as we could see
by like trying just now um the old
solution
um has some problems because there's
always like illumination changes
um there can be occlusions from foliage
and neighboring fruits
there could be overlapping fruits so in
the end
it makes sense to go to deep learning
because it's best with like dealing
with unstructured environments um this
is like approximately
the algorithm you can use um so that's
what the other group did
um see i think that's all
yeah so this is this is my like two
examples um of conforming
um yeah and i'll go check the chat if
you have any questions
let me know
thank you
[Music]
yes i will definitely share the notebook
i will add it
in the end
[Music]
oh so have you figured out how to map
and divide output to crop yield or some
other valuable crop metrics
i didn't try unfortunately with other
metrics um
yeah but if you want i can definitely
get back to you i also want to take a
look at it
um but i think there's definitely a
possibility
to do that um are you planning to post
the deep learning network into the goal
from you on a repository
uh so that one is actually um
it was um i don't have it right now
i tried to contact the researchers and
they did
um oh yeah the papers actually the paper
is right
here it's called counting apples and
oranges with deep learning
it's a pretty good paper um yeah very
fun to read um
yeah and then uh i don't have the
neural network to upload and i didn't
train it
using mathematica which i think would be
nice um
but yeah the the other group i think
they used
some other language and like they never
really shared it
um but i'll try to work on that
yeah but at least the paper is here um
yeah if you're like super interested all
the researchers
that wrote this paper pretty nice in
like replying
so yeah oh yeah yeah okay i'm
i'm gonna try to see how
i can access the participants
um allowed to talk
does that work christian
yeah can you hear me now yes i can hear
you
thank you first of all thank you for
your great presentation um so i have
um my first question is so i see that
what you do here is basically
post processing of images right um
do you see any use case of doing
real-time
processing of this data real-time
processing
um yeah i think actually that's what
they were trying to do like the original
project so the pictures that i got in
the dataset
are actually like extracted from videos
so
what they try to do is to use the drone
and just like make it fly
right next to the trees and like make a
video at the same time
so that it's like in real time tells you
how much
fruits you're getting so you go by one
treat so it's like oh like there's 15
you go by the next
says oh now it's like 40. um so that was
like the original idea
to be able to like walk around the field
and take a video and just like
see how many fruits you're getting um
yeah
i don't know if that's what you meant
yeah like like if you had
uh water language running on the drone
you could do that you could process all
that data while you
apply it run and also are you planning
to
add your ndvi function to the function
repository
oh my god yeah i think i will definitely
do that i totally forgot
um i'll i'll add it and i'll i'll talk
to you
anything thank you very much yeah thank
you
uh so okay i'm reading this other
question um
have you got any links to papers or
explored counting orchard trees from
above
for example satellite imaging uh
so i mean definitely i used to read more
papers than that i'm not sure about
satellite images
imaging um if i really focused on it
i tried to like do more uh try to read
more research like around using drones
but even with using drones i know it's
like it can be super expensive
um especially if you're like trying to
create a new one and use a bunch of
cameras on it which is
what mostly people did in the past um
but yeah okay uh i can try actually
i will go back like after the
presentation and look at all
like the folder with all the research
i've read i can put it in the chat
hopefully it stays here um just like a
bunch of links that i've used
but i don't think i look that much at
the intellect satellite imaging
um and i'll add the function thank you
for sure
oh okay sorry i just skipped one um
how one get a close estimation of fruit
counting in a tree as some may be hidden
in leaves yeah
that's uh like the biggest problem for
this one
so yeah for me it's like i just like
played with parameters but again it's
yeah it's just like one picture um and
ideally i think in this case deep
learning may be
better because in neural networks like
it's not just the information that you
provide
like in the images that i have but also
what the neural network learned itself
um like based on the thousand images it
processed so i think in this case
really like deep learning might be
better at recognizing
um but i haven't really like tried to go
deeper into using the functions that we
have to
see if like i could estimate it a little
better
for now that's just what i have um these
functions but
uh yeah that's something i still think
about
okay so what do you see as next steps in
your research
um so like ideally i actually i don't
know if i wanted to continue this one in
particular
um like it just took me a lot of time to
like learn about this new field because
it was so new like a lot of things that
i was trying to do
it was only maybe like one other group
on the internet that i found who tried
to do something similar
and that's why like i try to like tell
people about it more
and like the um one of the students at
this summer camp
who took this the at least like the idea
of the ndi function
and did something that was that was
interesting to him that's like totally
different
so i'm always like up for that
uh but for me i think i would definitely
want to look more into like the issues
with
pictures for example if you sometimes
you take a picture and you have
um since you're relying on like how dark
it is like the map how dark it is
um sometimes you also get um
just um what is the shadows yeah like if
you take it in the sun
you have the shadows which confuses you
it's like i still don't really know how
to deal with like
those type of issues and i'd love to
take a look at that
uh and maybe just like talk to
biologists more to be honest
i just see how like how you can actually
identify
if um like vegetation is healthy or not
um okay i think i'm still
here right oh just like dropped for a
second um
yeah um yeah so deal more with like
the actual images and see if there are
any issues um
yeah i don't i don't actually want to
jump into deep learning right now i'd
better stay and just like research more
about like the the actual leaves um
i just like the vegetation how to figure
out that part
um let me also share it in the chat
and envy
yeah i think i'm going to end here and
um if you want you can come back
and try to get the nb i'm going to
upload it right now
and also import some more research
papers that i've read
in the chat so um i'll try to do it fast
um
let me close it right now but thank you
so much for attending i really
appreciate it and you can always reach
out to me
no problem at all i have my email or
just like
on the bathroom itself yeah you're very
welcome
i'm glad to talk more about this thank
you so much
you